this is really nuts they had the Miss  Universe Pageant I don't really care for  these things very much you're not  fooling me the person that I'm about to  show you is Miss Universe's new owner  this is a dude dressed up as a chick  sort of like a Mrs Doubtfire situation  enjoy  [Applause]  was that a wolf  [Applause]  hello the universe  what the hell is even that he's a dude  who dresses up like a chick and has  boobs and wears lipstick  from now on it's gonna be ran by women  owned by a trans woman for all women  and the future is for women women will  be in charge even though she's not a  woman and then all the women stared up  oh my God that's a woman I guess or  something